[Musique]
ce programme est trop dure il n'est pas
réaliste et il provoquera créé blocage
dans le souci c'est qu'on sent interview
dit par françois fillon en margaret
thatcher icône ultra libérale elle est
cocasse d'excellentes pourquoi
ça fait drôle d'abord ça m'inspire pas
grand chose tout ça
peut-être un peu caricatural en tout cas
c'est clairement le candidat d'une
droite bourgeoise traditionnel
ultralibéral ce que propose françois
fillon c'est plutôt moins que ce que
freud heures pas mis en place en 2004 en
allemagne qui à l'allemagne
souvenez-vous avec 10% de chômage à
l'époque aujourd'hui l'allemagne à 4 %
de chômage en 2013 vous raconter que
françois fillon vous a dit tu ne seras
pas ministre car tu es enceinte et c'est
le sujet anciens mangez pas du tout
envie de ramener ça dans le débat
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui françois fillon
est la cible de toutes les attaques les
attaques de la gauche c'est normal les
attaques du front national c'est normal
mais aussi quand même les attaques de
mes amis juppéiste j'ai pas envie
d'argumenter sur un sujet sur lequel par
ailleurs il avait regretté il m'avait
dit voilà il avait dit j'avais trouvé ça
d'ailleurs élégant car j'aimerais bien
que françois fillon clarifie sa position
est par exemple sur l'avortement
l'interruption volontaire de retraite de
grossesse il a commencé par dire dans
son livre que c'était un droit
fondamental de la femme et puis il est
revenu sur cette déclaration
jamais je n'aurais pu penser que mon ami
alain juppé pongo cyborg ça fait trente
ans que je suis parlementaire est ce
qu'une seule fois j'ai pris une position
contre l'avortement une seule fois il
est probable que dimanche prochain
françois fillon et ses alliés
confirmeront ce résultat en tout cas moi
c'est mon souhait comme je les dis
dis c'est pour la vie pour la famille et
je préfère ce qui me peine ces quelques
attaques que j'ai considéré comme en
dessous de la ceinture et pas dignes de
la relations personnelles que j'ai avec
un ajout paix mais je mets ça sur le
compte de la déception et puis peut-être
aussi d'un certain énervement de son
entourage face au danger alain c'est
quelqu'un qui a la tête froide qui a du
sang froid qui a du courage et il me
rassure aussi face là à la montée ici en
france de tous ces extrémismes de tous
ses excès part j'ai toujours été très
correct avec un l'egypte et je crois
même l'avoir défendu qu'ont certains
attaqué sur ses sont passés sur les
questions judiciaires ont soif il y aura
le soutien de nicolas sarkozy ce qui
reconstitue l'équipe de 2007 2012
nous en aurons besoin françois hollande
nous laisse une france en dépôt de bilan
économique et morale une fonction
présidentielle a baissé dans le dernier
bouquin là qui fait des records en
librairie part et il n'ya qu'une seule
chose de bonnes c'est le titre ce qu'un
président de la république ne devrait
pas dire marc françois hollande visé par
une enquête préliminaire pour
compromission de défense nationale en
course d information relative à un
projet de frappe française en syrie en